let's turn out to one of our other
favorite things about the Emmys all the
red carpet fashion but what get in
there's half the battle so let me tell
you about it it truly takes a village
but I was lucky enough to get some help
from the man who just did Sidney's
Richard's wedding gown designer to the
stars mark Zunino Mark Zunino mark
Zunino dress I wore the red dress by
Mark Zunino Beyonce Mariah Katie and
Brittany have all worn his creations so
who might be wearing a Zunino dress to
the Emmys well we have dresses out for
Jessica Biel Laura Dern Sarah Paulson
Lily Tomlin Jessica Biel like you might
not know until the day out that's what
happens with them we get stylist Paul
and they get so much so we never know
know so it's just as exciting for me
when they hit the red carpet Sofia
vegara it turned heads on the Emmy red
carpet last year but didn't choose marks
strapless white dress until the last
minute it was actually supposed to be a
bridal gown she came in I had a line of
wedding gown she said that mark is great
of midium my red carpet looks and I
visited his Atelier in Beverly Hills to
check out what I just might wear to the
Emmys when you sent the sketch over I
was like oh my gosh that is so gorgeous
yeah I thought this is kind of geometric
and very sophisticated a little more
edgy than soft so I'm anxious for you to
slip it on and I really love the nude
fabric illusion panels on the arm I
think the color nude is good kind of
just disappears I'll just make sure
thank you mark very much we're doing my
dress and you're gonna look amazing I
can't wait to see you put all together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]